[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I want to thank
everyone for coming.
This is our last event here at
Cambridge for our Black History
Month programming.
And today we have
Rep Byron Rushing.
If you're not familiar
with him, in 1982,
Rushing was elected
as a Representative
of the Massachusetts
House of Representatives.
And he was the chief sponsor of
the law to end discrimination
on the basis of sexual
orientation in public schools
and an original sponsor of the
Gay Rights Bill Massachusetts.
Rushing also led the
Massachusetts State Pension
Fund to large community
development investment
of poor communities
in Massachusetts.
Rushing is an elected deputy
to the General Convention
of the Episcopal Church, a
founding member of Episcopal
Urban Caucus, and serves on the
board of the Episcopal Women's
Caucus and the Episcopal
network for Economic Justice.
In addition to being
a local politician,
he is also a
phenomenal historian.
And he's going to give
a little bit of context
on slavery as it pertains
to Massachusetts.
And I find this to be
particularly interesting
because I know that it's common
context slavery as a Southern
phenomenon.
And people don't really talk
about the occurrence of it
in the North, particularly
in the New England area.
So I'm sure this will be a great
little talk, so here he is.
[APPLAUSE]
BYRON RUSHING:
Thank you very much.
It's really good to be
with you this afternoon.
And I understand
I got squeezed in.
This is February 28.
But I do want to say--
you've probably
heard this already.
But I want to just
reiterate it because we
have a lot of discussion, both
inside the white community as
well as the black community,
about Black History Month.
And so I want to just say a
word about the origin of Black
History Month.
Black History Month derives
from what was clearly an attempt
to strengthen the
teaching of black history
not in white schools,
but in black schools.
Black History Month's
origin goes back
to the segregated South.
It actually
originated a few years
after World War I, when
a group of black teachers
went to a group of black
historians, scholars,
academics, and
asked them for help
in what they should teach about
black history in their schools.
A favorite word, title, for
black people, of course,
in those days was Negro.
And what was invented
was Negro History Week.
And Negro History
Week was to be a time
when the teachers,
who had been teaching
Black History and Black
Cultural Studies all year round,
would have a time when their
students could show off,
when their students
could come and talk
about what they learned
and write poems and read
short stories and read short
papers that they had written,
whether they were in elementary
school, junior high school,
or high school.
And one of the
things, of course,
that those teachers,
most of whom of course
were African-American,
one of those things
that was new in that
segregated system was they
could teach anything,
as long as they didn't
teach about ending segregation.
Then they'd get fired.
But otherwise, white
people didn't care
what they taught black kids.
And so they used that
opening, that opportunity,
to talk about black
culture to black kids.
But they felt not
unprepared to do that.
And the person who came
up with this whole idea
and advancing this
curriculum was
a historian at Howard University
named Carter G. Woodson.
And he came up with the idea
of doing Negro History Week,
and he came up to the idea
of creating a magazine called
"The Negro History
Bulletin," which
was designed for
teachers to help
them build their curricula.
He chose this week in February,
this Negro History Week
in February.
I suspect that if most of the
black historians who took part
in this whole program to advance
the teaching of black history
in segregated schools, most
of which were in the South,
if they had been
all Northerners,
we probably wouldn't
have picked February.
But they picked February.
And they picked February
because in February
two dates that they considered
good dates to celebrate
occurred.
One was February 12, and the
other one was February 14.
Now, I don't know if
is anybody here-- no
you're too young to know,
to remember, probably
that we had two holidays in
February, one for Lincoln.
That was February 12.
And the other one was for George
Washington on February 22.
And then they got merged
into Presidents' Day, which
is truly the second silliest
holiday on our calendar.
First is Columbus Day.
And then following Columbus
Day comes Presidents' Day.
All of you could make
a list of presidents
you don't think we should
have ever mention again,
let celebrate.
But the other date
that was chosen,
that that was important and was
close to the 12th was the 14th.
And February 14, anybody?
No, don't say Valentine's.
February 14?
February 14 was the birthday
of Frederick Douglass.
And of course, Abraham
Lincoln and Frederick Douglass
were contemporaries but lived
very, very different lives.
Though they did have
an interesting group
of similarities.
But Frederick
Douglass, of course,
had run away from slavery when
he was enslaved in Maryland.
And like a number
of slaves, he had
no idea what day he was born.
And so when he was
free, he realized
that people had birthdays
and he wanted a birthday.
And he chose the day, just
like many African-Americans
who escaped from slavery.
They chose a day,
for whatever reason,
that they would now
consider their birthday.
And they didn't know
their birthday because--
and this gets into
what I'll be speaking
about for the next few minutes--
because, as enslaved
people, there
were records kept about them.
But the records that were
kept about enslaved people
were generally not in
any official registry
at a county or city hall.
They were not even in most
birth registries and churches.
Where their records were
not with other human beings.
Their records were with animals.
They were treated by most
plantation owners as animals.
And so if you go to today
Thomas Jefferson's farm books,
all of his records of
all of the farming that
was done at Monticello,
if you go there now,
they are preserved, his
records of how many sheep
were born, how many
cows were born,
how many pigs were purchased.
And in those records
you will find also
how many slaves were born and
the records of their purchase
or sale, their
death, all in those
records because, of
course, they were property.
And I want to start there
with this discussion
about the ending of slavery
by talking about first what
was ended, what was abolished.
We don't talk a lot about
slavery in this country.
We talk about slavery usually
in discussions of its ending.
There's not a lot of discussion
about its beginnings.
There's not a lot of
discussion about it's middle.
Slavery and the slave
trade in the Americas
existed longer than
emancipation and civil rights
for the descendants of
slaves has yet existed.
If you use one of the shortest
periods of slavery, where
most of the slave
masters were British,
if you're talking about
slavery in North America,
slavery started about 1619.
And it's the approximate date
of the introduction of slavery
into the colony of Virginia.
The slavery then, if
you use as its ending
in what became
the United States,
slavery existed until 1865.
Many of us always when we
think about the end of slavery
think about the
Emancipation Proclamation.
The Emancipation
Proclamation, of course,
was a war proclamation.
And it did not free
all the slaves.
It only freed certain slaves.
And that was done in 1863.
But slavery ended in the United
States for the whole country
legally by amending
the Constitution.
And that was the passage of
the 13th Amendment in 1865.
And so if you quickly do
those numbers, that arithmetic
between 1619 and 1865, you
get to 246 years of slavery.
Add 246 to 1865 and
you get what year?
2111.
So it will not be until 2111
that people of African descent
will have been free
in the United States
as long as they
had been enslaved.
This is a defining
cultural aspect--
political, economic,
and cultural aspect
of American history.
You cannot discuss American
history accurately without
spending that proportion of
time and energy and words
and pictures on slavery as we
do on the years after slavery.
This is important
because slavery has
become, in many ways, mythic.
And if we are going to move
from the myth of slavery
as an incidental occurrence
that just happened--
there were a few
people who decided
they wanted to own
people, but generally it
is not what moved this country
to become this country.
If we are going to move
from the myth of slavery
as an incidental occurrence
in the early days
of the European
occupation of the Americas
to the true accuracy
of slavery as part
of the truth of the origins of
the nations of the Americas,
and specifically of the
origins and economic success
of the United States, it
will require the production
of a new history.
It will require the production
of a more accurate history.
It will require the
production of a new paradigm
about the invention of America,
the invention of the United
States.
And I'm using paradigm here in
the sense of the stories which
we combine into a set
of experiences, beliefs,
and values that affect the
way we perceive ourselves,
perceive our origin.
So let me start with an
origin story about slavery
in Massachusetts.
So listen carefully, because I
want to get these words right.
So I'm going to quote the
first colonial governor,
the leader of the Puritans who
invaded Massachusetts in 1630.
I start with the Puritans
because for a whole variety
of reasons, I think we should
all ignore the pilgrims.
I hope there's no one here
from Plymouth, Massachusetts.
The pilgrims, of course, were
a small group of Protestants,
literally from one
congregation, that decided
to come to the Americas.
And of course, as
many of you know,
they thought they were
going to northern Virginia.
Most people think the captain
knew where he was going,
just didn't tell the people,
pilgrims who were on the ship.
And of course, the Mayflower
gets to the coast, ends up
in Provincetown.
Those of you who
go to Provincetown
know there's a big
tower in Provincetown
that is commemorating the
first landing of the pilgrims.
And before the
captain takes off they
realize they have
no fresh water.
And they insist that
he take them someplace
where there's fresh water.
And the place that
he takes them is
what becomes-- which is the
place that they name Plymouth.
And if it wasn't for
a number of reasons
why pilgrims became part of the
mythology of the whole United
States, which mostly happened
after the Civil War, none of us
would know about them,
or maybe just the people
who live in Plymouth.
One ship-- they didn't fill
up the ship, "The Mayflower."
A few years later,
the Puritans invade.
The Puritans are a
party, both a church
and political party in England.
And they are attempting to
overthrow both the government
and reform the church.
This group that
comes to the Americas
lands in several places.
And the most northern
place that they land
is what is going to become the
colony of Massachusetts Bay.
When they are here about
6 and 1/2 or 7 years,
they come to a serious conflict
with the indigenous people who
are here.
The English always
knew there were
going to be indigenous
people when they got here.
The English, when
they came, assumed
that they could take
the land that was here.
It never dawned on them that
they should send ambassadors
over to negotiate with
the people who were here.
We can't imagine that.
We smile.
Every time I say that
to audiences, everyone,
well, not everyone, but
many people just smile.
The idea is just completely out
of our paradigm thing, the idea
that we would have
asked to be invited.
And so the Puritans come.
And within 6 and
1/2 years, they are
engaged in serious
violent conflict
with some of the Indian nations
that are in Massachusetts
and south of Massachusetts.
And they have a major
conflict which historians have
come to call the Pequot War.
John Winthrop in his
journal writes this,
"we had now slain and
taken in all about 700.
We sent 15 of the boys and two
women to Bermuda by Mr. Pierce.
But he missing it, carried
them to Providence Isle."
What has happened is that
the decision after that
this conflict is over,
the English have won.
The next decision
that has to be made
is what to do with all
of the Native Americans
that they have
captured, the POWs.
And they decide to
sell them into slavery.
They understand that it's going
to be too difficult to sell
them into slavery,
right, in a land
that they have lived
in for generations
and the Puritans have only
known for less than a decade.
And so they decide to sell
them into slavery away.
Bermuda is one place that
they think about sending them.
They had already
sent other Indians
that they had
captured to Bermuda.
But the captain,
for whatever reason,
decides to go to a
Puritan colony that
had been founded a few
years before Massachusetts
off the coast of
Central America which
they call Providence Isle.
He goes there.
And then in February--
interesting-- 26, 1638
we have this notation
in Winthrop's diary.
"Mr. Pierce in the
Salem ship the Desire,
returned from the West
Indies after seven months.
He had been at
Providence, and brought
some cotton, and tobacco,
and Negroes, from thence."
This is the first
record, written record,
that we have of Africans
arriving in Massachusetts.
There is so much to say
about these two notations.
I will only note that
in this whole story
I can tell you the
name of the ship.
name of the captain
of the ship, Mr. Pierce.
I can tell you where they went.
I can tell you the dates.
The one thing I cannot
tell you are the number,
the actual number, and the
names of the Africans that were
brought back.
When Pierce gets
to Providence Isle,
he might have seen
Africans for the first time
in his whole life.
The Puritans on Providence
Isle had already
begun to engage in the
African slave trade.
He sells the Indians and buys
Africans and brings them back
to Massachusetts.
We assume all
entered into slavery.
And these first slaves
in Massachusetts
were owned by the colony.
The founders of what the
United States is today
are all in the story.
This is an example of an
alternative founding story.
It is a founding story
that you could probably
find other examples in
in almost every colony,
be them French,
Spanish, Portuguese,
or as these North
America, British.
The founders of
whom we are today
as a nation, the aboriginal,
the native people, the English,
the Europeans, and
the Africans, what
in our language, in
our almost slang,
came to be known as the red,
the white, and the black.
And they all-- if we are to
have an accurate history,
they all must be in
this new paradigm
if it is to approach the truth.
Now, this new
paradigm is not going
to undo big chunks of the sacred
scripture of the old paradigm.
So "we the people of
the United States,
in order to form a more
perfect union" can stay.
"We hold these truths
to be self-evident,"
that all can stay.
Those were quite
remarkable statements.
No one denies that.
There's is a great book on the
history of 18th century slavery
called "Bury the Chains,"
in which the author says
that "at the end of the
18th century, well over 3/4
of all people alive in the world
were in bondage or were masters
of people who were in bondage."
So the basic idea of freedom
being innate to people
was an incredible, radical idea.
But as Frederick Douglass
would say a few years later
when he was asked to comment
on the celebration of the 4th
of July in the United
States in a speech in 1852,
"pride and patriotism,
not less than gratitude,
prompt you to celebrate
and to hold it
in perpetual remembrance.
I have said that the
Declaration of Independence
is the ring bolt to the chain
of your nation's destiny.
So indeed I regard it.
The principles contained
in that instrument
are saving principles.
Stand by those principles.
Be true to them on all
occasions, in all places,
against all foes,
at whatever cost."
And all of the minority groups
that have felt themselves
oppressed in the United
States have always turned back
on the majority group
their scripture,
their Declaration of
Independence, their United
States Constitution.
But if we do not
include the other people
as people, not as
property, not as inferior,
but people who
are innately free,
then we look at the founders
in a very different way.
Native Americans,
they were here.
They were here and, of
course, as you know, here
for thousands and
thousands of years.
But Europeans had developed a
politics and a theology that
allowed them to believe
that in their superiority
they could go anywhere in the
world that was not Christian
and claim it for themselves.
If you had asked
these people why
did they think
they could do this,
if you had asked Winthrop why
he thought he could do this,
if you had asked the French and
the Spanish and Portuguese who
preceded him, why do you
think they could do this,
they would not say
because they are white.
They wouldn't say because
they are European.
They hadn't gotten
that concept yet.
They would have said
because we are Christian.
And so when Europeans got
into a conflict over who
could take which land from what
they described as infidels,
they didn't go to their king
to ask him to resolve this.
They had no law that they could
go to to have it resolved.
Where did they go?
They went to the pope.
They went to the pope
because the pope was
head of Western Christianity.
And that was who would
make the decision
about dividing the world in
half between the Portuguese
and the Spaniards.
Native Americans have
their land stolen.
Sometimes that land was
stolen with warfare.
Sometimes that war
was stolen by deceit.
But essentially it was stolen.
And when you steal
land, you want
to make sure that the owner
of the land that was stolen
has no place in the
legal or political system
where they can protest,
even at a later date.
And so the only
good Indian is a?
How many people know
the end of that?
Raise your hand.
Where did you learn it?
It wasn't in your textbooks.
It's part of the paradigm--
part of the paradigm,
part of the culture.
And having stolen the land,
and of course, by the time
the British were there,
it was a regular thing.
There was nothing
they had to think up.
Having stolen the land, a
remarkable thing occurs.
And that in order to
exploit all of this land,
these people from these
tiny little countries,
principalities,
kingdoms in Europe,
struck by the amazing amount
of what was there cannot figure
out a way to exploit it to its
fullest with only Christian
labor, with only white labor.
And so they steal people.
They steal labor.
They steal Africans.
And that, of course,
is the origin
of the slave trade
in the Americas.
So we don't have a
lot in this room.
But probably watching we have
more people of African descent.
I can tell you one thing
about your ancestors,
if your ancestors
came to the Americas.
You belong to the only group
of people in the Americas
whose ancestors came
here fully employed.
Slavery-- about labor for free.
Now, how do you
break out of this?
You break out of this
by first, I think,
probably even before you
do the theology, probably
by the logic.
I think people who
first started to argue,
white people who started
to argue against slavery
argued because of the logic.
If you bought into the idea that
all people were free and then
immediately caught yourself and
realized you weren't talking
about all people, at what
point does logic hit you
over the head and say,
how can I not include
so-and-so, that group, those
people, that sex, women?
How can I not include
them in the all?
Unfortunately it was
not the majority view.
But almost from
the beginning there
was protest to the idea
of enslaving people.
And there was protest to the
idea of not including everybody
in the "all."
For the slaves in
Massachusetts, they of course
had no question
about the answer.
They had no question
about the answer,
but they had no power
to work it through.
And so they, from
the very beginning,
began making alliances
with those Europeans,
those Americans, those
white Americans who
felt that way, even though
they were in a minority.
In Massachusetts, that
logical position fortunately
got to the level of our
state Supreme Court.
And so three years after
the state of Massachusetts
adopted its state constitution,
which incorporated many
of the words of the
Declaration of Independence,
had what it called itself
a declaration of rights,
that constitution was being
interpreted by a brand newly
created supreme judicial court.
And several of the cases
around ownership of slaves
came to that court.
And eventually the court
decided that one judge
could decide them, their Chief
Justice, Justice Cushing.
And he writes an opinion that
under the state constitution,
obviously not the United
States Constitution,
but under the
Massachusetts Constitution,
no one could be enslaved.
It happened early in the 1780s.
By 1790, when the first United
States census was taken,
the only state in
Massachusetts of the 13
that recorded no slaves in
the census was Massachusetts.
Only Massachusetts in
1790 enumerated no slaves.
And of course, one of the
reasons for the census
was to determine
representation in Congress.
And the Southern states, in
forming the Constitution,
had insisted that
they be able to count
the slaves toward the formula
for that representation.
And the compromise was that they
could come up with a fiction
that for every slave they
had, who they did not
believe was human,
who could not vote,
would be recorded
as 3/5 of a person.
And so we had to know how
many slaves there were.
And Massachusetts
comes out of this
in 1790 with its clear mark
that slavery is ended here.
I have no doubt that there were
a few that were still enslaved.
But when the census
taker came by,
they knew enough to say, oh,
no, Mabel's my servant, right?
But they did not get recorded.
I hope there's no one
here from Vermont.
Anyone from Vermont?
Because all the Vermont people
always tell me they were first.
Except they weren't a state.
They thought they would
try to be a republic first.
And when there were
republic, that is true.
Vermont's constitution
as the republic
said that they would
have no slaves.
They didn't come into the Union
until 1791 as the 14th state.
This feeling of anti-slavery
grows in Massachusetts.
But it has one huge
contradiction-- a lot
of little contradictions,
one huge contradiction.
And that contradiction are the
people who dealt in the trade.
And Massachusetts ports were
just ideal for harboring
and sending out slave ships.
And so many capitalists
in Massachusetts
insisted on, although they
would have no slaves themselves
in Massachusetts,
in trading slaves.
And the trade for
slaves went on until--
legal trade for slaves
went on until 1808.
The Constitution, in the
United States Constitution,
slave trading was
given a 20-year break.
So right in the
Constitution in says
that 20 years after the
ratification of this document,
then Congress
could begin to pass
laws ending the slave trade.
That was done because
of the huge number
of slaves who ran away during
the American Revolution.
There is one
historian who argues
that it was the largest slave
rebellion in United States
American history was
the American Revolution.
Not only could they run
away, and most of them
got their freedom
by running away--
white people were
fighting white people.
What a better time
to leave, right?
But they also negotiated.
And they negotiated with both
the British and the Patriots
to fight and to help
them in their war effort.
And as a reward be
given emancipation,
be manumitted if they survived.
And many of them did--
approximately half with the
British and the other half
with the Patriots.
And the British kept their
word for most of them,
and most of them who
were freed went to Canada
with a lot of Tory Americans
who went there also
after the American Revolution.
Into the 1900s, emancipation
grows throughout the country,
throughout the northern
part of the country.
And the issue becomes whether
we can survive as a state,
as a country that is
divided between free states
and non-free states, if we
can survive as a country.
And in that way, the first
set of political struggle
is over what to do with
all the new states.
What to do with all the Western
lands that are becoming states.
All the Western lands that have
been stolen from the Indians,
should those lands be free or
slave in this growing country?
That is the argument that the
Lincoln-Douglas debates was all
about--
expansion of slavery.
And finally, it comes to
a head in the Civil War.
When the Civil War is
over, when the Africans
believe that they will be free.
And many of them are free.
Most of them for
moments are free.
And as they struggle
to get the experience,
as they struggle to get the
skills to live as free men
and women, the major population
in the South decide that they
cannot tolerate it.
And so we have a period, a kind
of creative political hiatus,
which we call
Reconstruction, and then
white people in the
North and the South, who
have been killing each other,
at the end of that generation
decide that they want to unite.
They want to reunite, and as
a condition of that reuniting,
the Southern white people argue
that they must have control
of the Africans in their midst.
It is a difficult history.
It is a history that
informs how we operate
as residents, members,
citizens of the United States
to this moment.
There probably are no
major political arguments
in this country that do not
have strong, accurate analogies
in the history of Africans in
this geography and the history
of Native Americans.
Except it is not approached.
It is not directly taught.
It is not directly thought
about as we go forward.
The problem of
history, of course,
is that it can be like memory.
And like memory, if you lose
it, you get disoriented.
If you lose your
memory, you actually
do not know where you are.
And this disorientation
makes it difficult to make
decisions about the future,
similarly in history.
If we have a history that is
allowed to contain the gaps,
that our history is
allowed to contain,
that the decisions that we
make as citizens, as a people,
are decisions made
from disorientation,
they're decisions
made from untruths.
And so the task for
black history, of course,
is not simply the
study of black history.
The task of black history is
not to set aside a few days
or a month to think about it.
The task of black history
is to drive the argument
that history has to be honest.
And that when truth is
the criteria for history,
no one will have
to have a month.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
about how many slaves there
were in Massachusetts when the
supreme judicial court gave
that ruling.
BYRON RUSHING: Just under 5,000.
AUDIENCE: Out of how many?
So what proportion?
That's larger than I
would have thought.
BYRON RUSHING: That
would have been about 3%.
AUDIENCE: OK.
BYRON RUSHING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This kind of
a follow up to that.
I sort of had this
idea in my head
that one of the reasons
why slavery was abolished
so early in the
North was because it
wasn't as fundamental to the
economy as it was in the South.
Is this an accurate
idea, or do you
think things would
have been different
if there were a lot more
plantations in Massachusetts?
Or am I thinking
about this wrong?
BYRON RUSHING: No, that's
a very good question.
And I think that what slavery
in large numbers means
is that the whole society has
to adjust to having slaves.
And some historians have
actually described--
they separate what they call
slave societies, like the South
before the Civil War,
all of the West Indies.
That there was just
nothing that could
happen that could be
done without taking
into consideration
its effect on slavery
or slavery's effect on it.
But that you could still have
the idea of owning people.
It was just incidental.
And so in Massachusetts, and
I think most of the North,
it was incidental.
What is interesting
about Massachusetts
is even though it was an
incidental-- certainly helps
the argument about freeing.
But then when you look at
all the other Northern states
at the time of the
Civil War, slavery
was still legal in half
of the Northern states.
So people found an economic
advantage in owning people,
right?
And there were enough people
taking that economic advantage
and owning people who did not
find a political or economic
contradiction in doing that.
And even in Massachusetts
probably the most--
but it is true that the
more economic advantage
there is for slavery, the harder
it is to build up the argument.
And most slaves in Massachusetts
of that population by then
worked in houses.
They worked as
servants and houses,
or they worked in
small businesses.
They worked in taverns.
And our only large
agricultural use of slavery
was in the Connecticut
River Valley
when we grew tobacco
in Massachusetts.
AUDIENCE: Do you think
the textbooks that
are used in
Massachusetts schools
accurately represent
true history?
And if they don't, why
do you think that is?
BYRON RUSHING: I think
the major reason why
we don't have that
accurate history
is because I think most of
us don't want to have it.
See, I think most
of us are-- and it's
not like an active
thing that we do.
But we think that the
founding stories that we know
make sense, that they
answer all the questions.
So you have to make a
judgment call about--
you can make a philosophical
judgment call about accuracy.
But you also have
to make a judgment
call of the connections--
of making sure you
see the connections.
So I suspect that the average
person in Massachusetts
doesn't really care
that they've never met
an Indian from Massachusetts.
They don't care.
It's not like, oh, I've
never met an Indian.
I wonder why.
So the most most of us know
about Native Americans,
the average person in
Massachusetts, is we
know all these places are named
after it, right, including
the name of the state.
We know that.
If someone asked you,
you would say, oh, yeah,
that's an Indian word, right/
so it is a kind of intentional
judgment call that
we need to make.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I wondering if you can
compare or contrast
the form that white
supremacy took
before the Civil
War with the form
that it took after
Reconstruction
and the segregation era
and maybe even a connection
to the Christian imperialism
you were talking about earlier.
BYRON RUSHING: Right.
I think while there's slavery,
certainly the people who
support that economy--
and the people who support
an economy of slavery
are not only the
slave masters, right?
So a slave economy has a lot of
people working for it, right--
free labor that
is not immediately
engaged in owning
slaves, because someone
has to supply all the other
stuff for the plantations.
But if in that group--
so the argument comes
up about the inferiority
of black people.
White people can quickly
join in supporting that idea.
It makes all the
rest of it easier.
So what happens when
you end that slavery?
And there are two
things I think happen
when you end that slavery.
One is you try to make
it as easy as possible,
and that did not happen
in ending slavery
in the United States.
It was not easy.
All the slave masters lost their
slave property-- all of them.
And they got no
compensation for that.
Even when the British abolished
slavery in the West Indies,
although the slave
masters complained,
that they didn't get enough
money, they were given money.
They were given some money for
the slaves that were now free.
And so you try to figure out how
you're going to make up that,
and so you shift the
nature of that prejudice
to keep black
people in a position
where you can still
exploit them economically.
And that, of course, happened
not only in the South,
but happened in the North.
But it took its most egregious
forms in the Southern states
by creating racial
segregation and insisting,
actually, on separation
that you didn't even
worry about with slaves.
So slaves were intimately--
and I use that word intimately--
involved with white
people in a way
that was illegal after
the slavery ended.
And so I think that
once the decision
is made that you are
not going to treat
people as free and equal,
or as you would say--
not you would say--
as one would say,
one white person
would say, you're not
going to treat people as white.
Then that prejudice shifts but
is there for the same reason--
to maintain that society where
oppression of another group
is legal.
I don't know if--
there used to be a phrase that
you don't hear much anymore.
It came from a
1940s movie, where
a young woman is complaining
about the way she's treated.
And her retort is, you
can't do that to me.
I'm free, white, and 21.
So two of those--
two of those-- were
directly related to race.
AUDIENCE: So first of all,
thank you very much for coming.
This has been a very
interesting talk.
One of the things I found
interesting that you mentioned
was how there's a
lot of parallels
between political issues
that happened 150 years ago
and things that happen today.
And I was wondering if you
could expand a little bit on one
of the things you mentioned.
You mentioned how
slavery in Massachusetts
was basically abolished by
a single judge's decision.
That, to me, sounds
like a very small thing.
And I'm sort of wondering
how did something like that
actually get
implemented in practice.
Because it seems
like today in 2017,
we also have situations where
judges' decisions are wide
reaching, and maybe it's not
so clear how they're actually
implemented.
So I was wondering if you could
talk about the process of how
we went from one judge's
decision to slavery actually
pretty much gone.
BYRON RUSHING: You need
to become a historian.
And you could go try to do some
more work on this because it's
a question that
keeps getting asked.
And most of us guess,
see, that there just
was a kind of
anti-slavery feeling
that hadn't been articulated.
You This was before
William Lloyd Garrison.
So people weren't writing
about it and stuff.
But there was just
a general idea
that we should get rid of this.
So when it happens, one of the
things that could have happened
is that the owner of the
slave in the dispute that
got to the Supreme
Judicial Court
could have appealed
to the whole court.
And he never does.
So even he, right, decides
it's not worth it, right?
And so that feeling
was just there.
Now, if you tried to
make a parallel to that
to the "Goodman" case a
few years ago on same sex
marriage in
Massachusetts, I think
the thing, of course,
that goes together here
is, of course, that we developed
a court that Massachusetts
citizens, to use a
conservative term,
were comfortable with
an activist court.
They would fight it
every once in a while.
But they were
comfortable that that's
an OK thing for judges
to say, that they
could dig into the
Constitution and come up
with this idea that's
not written directly
into the Constitution and make
it the law of the Commonwealth.
AUDIENCE: I guess I'm just sort
of thinking of the logistics
here.
I mean, 5,000 people is
still 5,000 different cases
where you basically are turning
someone's life upside down.
And maybe that it's the will
of 90% of the population
of Massachusetts.
But it seems amazing
to me that even in 1790
that we could actually
have agreed enough
that we were able to, in
a short period of time,
actually cause all of those
sleeves to become free.
BYRON RUSHING: Right.
And so we assume that--
and we know this
in a lot of cases,
not all of them,
because, again, there's
lots of gaps in that
history, is that, of course,
the Africans, right, hearing
about this, of course, leave.
So they say, I think
I need a salary.
I think this means
I can get a salary.
You have to pay me.
And the master says, no.
And he looks up the next day.
He's gone.
The slave's gone.
And there's no one.
He can't get the sheriff
to go after him, right?
So I think that there was enough
activism among the Africans,
and then there was this
broader-than-we-thought
abolitionist feeling in
the general population.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to
echo his thanks for coming
to speak with us today.
I've really enjoyed it.
I was wondering if we
could hear your thoughts
about the splitting
of Massachusetts
in what is now Maine in
the Missouri Compromise.
BYRON RUSHING: Well, I
think Massachusetts is--
well, so in the
Missouri Compromise,
of course, we decided
that the only way
we could keep the expansion
of the United States
from becoming the kind
of violent conflict
that eventually,
of course, it did
was that we would just
make sure that we always
had every time you invited a
free state, that you invited
a slave state.
And at that time there
was a movement in Maine
that they wanted to be
independent of Massachusetts
because they felt that the
people in Massachusetts
were simply using
Maine to make money.
And we did.
If you go through the budget
of the state of Massachusetts
before, what year was
that, 1821, '25, right?
We sold off huge amounts
of forest in Maine
and used that to support
the income of Massachusetts.
So there were a lot of
people up there that
were looking for something.
And this sort of
fell into their lap.
I don't know if they
could have done this
without being able to tie it
with this national concern
and then getting the support
of Congress to do that,
although there was still
opposition in Massachusetts
to it.
AUDIENCE: Hi Thanks
again for being here.
You referenced how in 1790
we were the first of the 13
to have no slaves
registered on the census.
And I think
Massachusetts has long
been a very proud politically
blue state and thinks
of ourselves as progressive
on many of these issues.
But since 1790, there have
been a number of incidents--
I think about
things like busing--
that have not necessarily
reflected that reputation.
And I think about
how often there
might be star athletes a Boston
team is trying to recruit.
And you see that
they get counseled
that Boston won't necessarily
be a welcoming place for them.
So I'm wondering if
you could comment
on the trajectory since 1790
and where we stand today
and perhaps what we can do
about that seeming reputation?
BYRON RUSHING: So I think that
if you look at that trajectory,
as you say, generally
it works out.
And generally, I think
Massachusetts citizens
have a kind of optimism
about huge controversies.
And I think it goes
all the way back.
So of course, before there
was the big 19th century
controversy in Massachusetts,
a human rights controversy
in Massachusetts was
not around Africans.
It was, of course,
around foreigners.
And it was around Roman
Catholic foreigners,
and it's specifically
Irish foreigners.
And so lots of the--
and very quickly,
many of the ideas
that people thought
they had settled
around civil rights
were challenged in
very negative ways
by the treatment of Roman
Catholics, and to the degree
that even for a few
years in Massachusetts
political history, an
anti-immigrant party
was able to gain control
of both houses of our state
legislature, the party that
became known as the Know
Nothings.
But it all got worked through.
And that at some
point, we always
found compromises to make,
or the oppressed minority
group got bigger, right?
AUDIENCE: Again, thank you
very much for coming here
to speak to us today
and also thank you
for your support on the Trans
Public Accommodations law.
So actually my
question is about--
so the 13th Amendment
accepts labor
as punishment for a crime.
So I'm curious your
thoughts on prison labor.
BYRON RUSHING: Well, let me
say about the 13th Amendment,
there's a movie
out, a documentary.
Government Have you seen it?
AUDIENCE: I've been meaning to.
BYRON RUSHING: So it's
called "13" because--
and it's interesting
that for a lot of people
it seems like a
reasonable statement.
And other people
argue, historians
argue that it was actually
a compromise even then
on emancipation.
And that was that
the last sentence
of the 13th Amendment--
I don't have it memorized--
speaks to the fact
that this does not affect
people who are in prison.
So the prisoners can't
argue, I can't be imprisoned
because you freed the slaves.
And that sentence is in the 13th
Amendment of the Constitution.
So whether it was thought
about at that moment,
it quickly became a vehicle
for especially Southerners,
but other Americans,
to engage in control
of people of African
descent by criminalizing
a number of deeds, a
number of misdemeanors
essentially, or
creating all new crimes,
where you could quickly
arrest people and then
keep them in jail in
incredibly unjust ways.
AUDIENCE: And that's still
going on to this day.
BYRON RUSHING: Right.
And so where does that
place any kind of labor
that we ask prisoners--
should prisoners get paid,
see, at the minimum wage
when they make license plates?
or furniture, which is done
a lot more in Massachusetts
than anything else
probably in our prisons?
And that raises an
excellent question
about the interpretation
of freedom,
and then where do you go forward
on that in terms of a reform?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So some of
the things you said--
the background is I grew
up in Massachusetts.
And so I had history
lessons here.
And it was interesting to
notice which parts of the things
had said were very
familiar to me,
like talking about the
Missouri Compromise and things
like that.
But at other hand, the context
definitely wasn't there.
For example, you
described the Puritans
as invading, which
completely fits
with what I know now and,
even if I think about it,
what I knew then.
But that was never said, right?
They never quite put
it in those terms.
So that seems like a really
important thing going forward
to try to make sure that
the kids who are growing up
in Massachusetts have
that view, like you
said, that paradigm instead
of some of the other ones.
I have no idea how to
affect that though,
or even how to
monitor it, right?
I'm no longer in school.
I don't have kids who I
can read their homework
and see, oh, that's what
they're being taught.
Do you have suggestions
for how we as a state
can try to push education
in that direction?
BYRON RUSHING: Well, see, I
would turn-- that question,
I really should ask
everybody in this room.
So the question is
really for you here,
how could Google affect that?
See, what would you need to
do to just raise that up so it
sort of becomes viral?
I do think part of this--
there's small things that we
can all just do as individuals.
And I think part of that
is we should be very
careful about our vocabulary.
We should be careful about
what does "discover" mean.
So this discover means that
I saw your car in the parking
lot.
And you forgot to
close the door, right,
so I discovered your car.
And so how do we
talk about this past
in words that make sense, that
are as accurate as possible?
And so "invasion," of
course, is one of those words
that we need to use
more often, I think,
in talking about
these early periods.
But I really leave it to you.
See, I think that it's the
communication piece of this
that really it comes to.
How do I talk about this?
How do I get other people to
engage in this conversation?
So I ask that to all of you.
AUDIENCE: I'm interested
in your thoughts
on the role of this highly
biased, deeply gapped,
false history that is often
taught in the United States,
the role in the 2016 elections,
and the impact on sort
of the rise of more
publicly espoused racism,
the alt-right and
so on, and thoughts
about what we as individuals and
we collectively as society can
do to push back against
this resurgence of some
of these views.
BYRON RUSHING: I'll say
two things about that
because this is a conversation.
I was just in a meeting
to talk about what
we should be doing in
Massachusetts about health
care, considering
everything that might
be getting ready to happen.
And the person started off
by saying, anybody tells you
that they know what's
going to happen
doesn't know what they're
talking about, right?
So we have to put
it in that context.
But one thing to understand,
I think, about this
is how different white
people are in this country.
And I think that
that is something
that everybody in
this country needs
to think about but I think
white people especially
need to think about--
how little they know
about other white people.
And so since the
election when I've
talked to predominantly
black audiences, I say,
I understand that we don't
know what's going to happen.
But generally it does
not look good, right?
But understand this.
You were surprised.
All your white neighbors
were surprised.
But there's one thing that you
were not, to black people--
you were not shocked.
Half of the white people
were shocked, right?
And you are not shocked
because you know that there
have been worse times.
And in your paradigm,
in your history,
you know that black
people have recovered
from worse times than these.
White people can't remember when
they recovered from worst times
than these.
So I think there are two things
that we need to do immediately.
And I think one of
them is that we all
need to be talking
about white people
and learning more about them.
And part of this is
not going to be easy,
and that is actually when
you learn more about them--
they're some good
books about that.
Every white person needs to
take a White Studies Course.
How many of you taken Black
Studies courses, right?
You need to take a
White Studies Course.
Then, how do we
talk to each other?
And those are huge questions.
And I don't know the answers.
See, I'm at the point
where I'm trying
to formulate the questions.
But I don't know the answer.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]